okay i have a few very compelling and
titillating announcements related to the
show that i want to make one is related
to this picture that is over my shoulder
and i'll talk about that last because i
know people are interested in that
number one internships available here in
our Boston studio we have some new
initiatives that we are launching and
that were sort of gonna be testing and
we always have opportunities for interns
to work in our Boston studio so if
you're in the Boston area and you can
commit to two days a week in our studio
is all that we ask for you won't be
getting coffee you'll be doing actual
work you'll be managing video
distribution you will be working on
projects you will be working on segments
you will be working on all sorts of
interesting stuff working with
advertisers planning future shows it's
fast paced you will learn a lot uh and
that's really it if you're interested
you can get in touch through the website
email at david or the website contact
form rather at david pakman.com uh right
in about your interest in participating
in the show and then we'll email back
and ask for a resume etc that is number
one big announcement internships get in
touch number two we are developing david
pakman show Koffee david pakman show
coffee will be available soon along with
the return of david pakman show t-shirts
and hoodies and bumper stickers we've
been rebuilding the store on the new
david pakman.com website that's why
t-shirts have not been available for a
little while and with that we are going
to bring in 2 roasts one is going to be
a david packard show espresso roast for
espresso machines the other is going to
be a drip coffee roasts for regular
coffee pots or chemex or french press or
whatever you use please help us come up
with interesting names for these 2
roasts we need two names our audience
came up with the term hey treat male and
so many other of the of the terms and
phrases and names for stuff on the show
so please email them in post in the
comments if you're watching this is a
YouTube video you can tweet me at dpac
Minh and we've also created a thread
on our reddit discussion forum for
suggestions on the coffee roasts names
and with no further delay the 2017 david
pakman show calendar is coming let me
show you first the cover the cover was
designed by david pakman show viewer dan
burke the cover is a fantastic cartoon
of me basically as the boxing ref
between Hillary Clinton and Donald Trump
you see obama in the background you see
Jeb Bush and so many people and the
entire calendar is comic book colouring
book themed so I'll show you just part
of one comic now every month has its own
comic or comics these were all designed
by Dan Burke if you want to think about
this as an adult coloring book as you
can see if you're watching with me this
would be a pretty cool coloring book if
you just want to put it up on your wall
then it is going to be what I call a
conversation starter calendar and uh the
themes very lewis is in some of these
comics rachel is in some of these I
mentioned this on the bonus show last
week unfortunately Pat is not in any of
the comics because he started after the
comics were done but I've I've told Pat
that there is no question Dan is going
to start including him in upcoming
comics in Europe you're not furious
about this right back yeah I mean it is
too bad but I'm looking forward to see
how I'm gonna be characterized in the
next edition yet the the the caricatures
in the comics are really really good so
the 2017 comic book style calendar it
will go on sale soon more details about
that later in the week